Kim Kardashian's kids have a total
meltdown in Japan having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot the mama Four's latest relatable
moment happened as her kiddos North
Saint Psalm and Chicago met famous
Japanese artist Takashi murakami whose
actually Pals with their dad Kanye West
kirakami is like top three pop artists
he's a good friend of mine so I just got
these like my Christmas present to
myself Kim says alongside her latest
shots from their trip abroad all North
wanted to do was Meet Takashi as for
Saint that's another story
yep that's the seven-year-old on the
floor crying then even pouting in a
separate snap as for why Saint wasn't
feeling it well Kim writes it would have
been nice if they weren't fighting
everyone gets along everyone loves each
other I'm rolling with it the mama bear
is also looking at the positive saying
and we got a decent picture but hey I
wouldn't take any of it back seems like
life following Kim and Kanye's divorce
is going well for the family A source
told E.T last month that although the
former couple is still having some back
and forth arguments co-parenting
healthily is their main goal which is
Kim's primary focus
I feel free in the sense
that I am not anybody else
I don't hold anyone else's
thoughts opinions burdens
and I used to hold this guilt that I
wasn't there
to fix situations and I wasn't there
to put it all back together as for how
the reality star feels about yay's new
alleged wife Bianca sensiri our Insider
says she doesn't have a problem with her
ex's new lady love Yeah Bible it's a
great look The Source ads Kim ultimately
wants the rapper to be at peace so if
Bianca helps with that then it's fine
and Kim's ready to take another shot at
love too but I think my next route will
I feel like I have to do something like
go to different places clearly it's not
working whatever I'm doing following her
public breakup with Pete Davidson last
August
et's learned Kim will date again one day
and she's more open to it at this point
she's just looking for someone that adds
to her life yep in the meantime seems
like Kim's just enjoying quality time
with her kids through all the highs and
the lows my house is so full but in the
best way it's it's
amazingly full
[Music]